[Music]
a
he
[Music]
w
a
[Music]
la
let
[Music]
what's it like inside of virtual reality
Rob Danny is that
you are you there oh you okay yeah I'm
fine I I was sleeping you look a bit
you're sleeping with your eyes open
that's right uh yeah I'm in some sort of
room man I I don't know what's going on
really we're all in some sort of room we
call it the Gamespot Studio it's a good
point we're here for congratulations to
Mary Kish for perhaps the best named
stream of the year so far UL Oculus rter
Michael mahardy hey how you doing good
you're doing pretty good you happy yeah
this makes me happier Rob's face yeah
Rob's face is pretty beautiful it's
great it was either going to be Oculus
rifters or VR Drifters oh okay yeah we
had multiple quality names for this one
it's true Rob thank you so much for
being our guinea pig for the start of
this stream we're going to play a bunch
of Oculus Rift games yeah we are I think
we're probably the three worst people to
be doing this I've basically not played
it since we got this unit have you
played it much at all I played about uh
geez probably about 30 seconds okay
right what about you Mike uh I played a
drift in it but and then a few demos but
I'm not experiences like Pete five out
of out of 10 a drift yeah great
experience we might get to a drift we're
going to oh sweet we're going to be
taking can't deal with this we're going
to be taking suggestions from the twitch
chat I got it right here on my games
SWOT brand new laptop uh so by all means
let us know uh we're also going to be
cycling you out for who Scott's coming
on Scott's coming on later sweet uh
Peter Bryan was going to join us but
he's probably reviewing VR games
actually we've also got the the
ridiculously brilliant Twitch Plays
robot which we've had in the office a
couple of times here I can hear it over
here you can hear yes it's right beside
your feet right now you have kid also
have to make sure you don't uh kick it
kick it yeah so that's on a different
stream so you can like if you want to
double screen this bad boy you can get
the virtual reality experience from as
many angles as possible oh it's oh it's
it's touching my foot daddy it is that's
the virtual
reality
uh anyways what game are we starting
with uh
albino lullabi is that it says I think
so okay uh yeah so I think part of the
idea is you know if these things get
boring which I have heard some of these
VR games might indeed be that we'll just
move right along yeah okay but we you so
you've actually not played any albino
lullabi at all not at all so this should
be
interesting maybe very entertaining or
might be a tot a car crash we're about
to find out whoa a bathroom it's typical
this is where I live what what what text
came up there uh I think it just
said uh
continue definitely I totally don't know
okay so I guess I just got moving
obviously for VR
yeah I hear noise it's your
footsteps what's the note
say fair day no stop using
my washroom that's me and my that's me
and my washing what is this what future
video games is I think the bigger
problem is Rob can't
read Rob are you literate is this what
we found out did you manage to get
through the tire hiring process without
anyone no I can read uh I just I just
don't like how this guy's handwriting is
I mean it's got strobe lighting I'm not
used to it and the strobe lighting and
I'm not used to reading in VR H in the
chat uh is asking is this the start of
Duke Nukem Forever it kind of yeah I can
see that so
all right I can
jump
uh whoa this is
weird have you guys played this one at
all no no yeah we're experiencing it
with you what's going you you in some
sort of moving room Al it's like the
start of Portal 2 or something mhm yeah
right there's something over there
what's that noise dude I don't know it
sounds like a bunch of people throwing
like balls against a backboard is this
like so
I hope so Rob to cut his leg off wait a
second or arm whatever it was this is
different rearrange I'm I'm thinking I'm
thinking things are are changing up on
me uh this person who lives here has a
fascination with
cockroaches uh I
don't they have a fascination with one
particular picture of
a
well I think they're all different but
cockroaches don't really uh diversify in
their profiles oh so so is this is like
this the whole family it's like the the
family
portraits that's Jim that's old Uncle
Steve Howard Earl oh Samantha you know
typically a red lock would would would
be like an indication of of a locked
room right I don't know that's weird
oh what's this can you read that one
whoa what what's that say anyone caught
feeling at
peeping come on I mean like it's is that
a p like am I really that illiterate
that's all right peeping at the
Ascension room from here will be Gravely
punished prove
it telling on Friends earns good
behavior
cards what's your feeling right now
feeling is moving through the are you
are you is are you anxious at all no not
really this dude doesn't really scare me
at all the Cockroaches kind of was like
all right you're weird I hope something
really scary out I Know It
Be I'm not really get like this is just
a bunch like where's the story I don't
know caution here's someone who see
here's someone who knows how to
write great handwriting good handwriting
right the bridge is passable we're
blocked did you hit that button uh I
did twitch this twitch robot is real
cool he's just butting you in the leg
over and over all right so this didn't
really do anything or I guess it did I
mean did it okay so there's something in
the way who knows
right all right these chairs can move
that's
tight this is the best part of the
game jump on can you jump on the chair
oh damn right
dude oh good
call all right what does this look like
something another
note
H it's weird it
like oh how do I pull up my notes again
ah
[__] whoa oh there it is read notes okay
good that is that really upsetting when
you hit a pause button and suddenly it
like changes the room you're in not
really I mean if you if you initiate it
it's like you expect it what is that
thing I guess
yeah someday one will wake up right in
the
middle till then I'll watch every one in
Hope like
what all right it's like all right dude
maybe it's not a human writing the notes
or a cockroach
yeah good maybe a handful of cockroaches
or doing it all at once Samantha's just
messing with us yeah I mean I'm going to
I'm going to if it's a cockroach I'm
going to redact my previous claim about
it being bad handwriting it's actually
pretty good handwriting for a
cockroach yeah right there a lot of
notes I feel like I'm playing Quantum
break yeah you know what I'm doing I'm
going to I'm going to if I see number on
it I'm assuming there's going to be like
a safe I need to open this is cool see I
can use the light to look at it
yeah I don't I don't care about that we
we need to speed this thing up you
know all right what's going on here it
is like we are basically playing these
these Oculus games in like the worst way
for trying to play like these type of
long formy ones like instead of it just
being like the mini game collection
which is actually the thing that most
people complain about is that most games
are quite Mini but I think they're the
ones we're probably going to jump into a
bit more after this one well those shoes
are saw like Chronos no exactly all
right who oh that's cool yeah sit in
that chair in
that they're saw blades What's that one
say it says there are all they are all
our children no matter their age be
gentle that is the creepiest note of
them all can you get in the note says
that's not a saw blade don't worry it's
a toothbrush just jumping into it is
this your this this your kind of
toothbrush Mike yeah you have great
teeth so that that's really insane it's
actually what a cockroach dentist chity
really looks like all right well this is
a bummer put your tendrils in the
tendril
spots all right well where these are
these doors or lockers are you a
cockroach is just a tiny cockroach in in
like a little model home yeah dude in a
doll's house dude
and even smaller cockroaches wrote the
notes Danny yeah that's real hot I like
that uh myth rad asks can we answer all
the most pressing VR questions there is
what is VR porn like Mary's done that I
have not she's experienced The Wonder of
the VR porn what do you call the one
goes the the H the the HDC One the Vive
no no no the one that was for the phone
oh uh remember that thing gear VR yeah
cuz Peter had one of those um and she
said it was pretty
shocking I would imagine so how does it
does it I don't I don't know you are
the
person hey guys I guess you could say
this game is on Rails
oh all right what's that say
stop does the child meet the four
security standards one let's see if you
meet the stand
sedated and unware of surroundings sure
are watching both eyes and all teeth
completely removed oh my God whoa this
is this is a fun game what three
confirmed biological VI viability
digestive tra permanently
removed turn tied off just tie it off
yeah you don't have the time you can
just like like a b bisectomy yeah
visectomy vasectomy how would a child
still be like walking if their
intestines were gone on that's why the
rails are there oh right going they're
sitting there oh good point you're on
you're on a seat no more accidents
answer no to any of the four standards
please press the button uh press the
button now do it I think we should right
see I got a bad feeling about
this oh see bad feeling oh put you
somewhere
else oh oh my wow that's very portal as
well actually that's what we do with
kids oh I'm getting on
this which wish I go guys
uh which way is the most screams coming
yeah right the right that way yeah yeah
might be a pool table there it looks
kind of cool looks kind of cool Jazz
Lounge it's pronounced
YZ nice work I you burn your face no you
didn't
oh God damn notes another noes it's
three days Quantum break Quantum break
has an appalling amount you know the the
note I wish would reposition cuz I have
to like
look centered is it back it's like not
centered no no no no it's the button
back button or I think if you press um
there you go no it it's it's like way
too high up so I have to like feel I
have to look up and it doesn't help what
the note or the the note itself is like
at the
top it's like I'm looking at the bottom
of it like it's the bottom of it is
centered if that makes sense so it's
like great for us so we don't
care right it Hur it hurts my eyes is
where I'm getting at I'm not reading
these I'm over
it Oh see
now this I have this one in my room my
own room this is a favorite of mine if
something creepy doesn't happen in the
next 5 minutes we're going to swap out
of the game I dude I am on
board so far the creepiest part were
those cockroach
paintings uh-huh
he's already at the stage where he's not
reading any of the notes oh that's
creepy go down there this this is
definitely a game that you like you know
you isolate yourself and yeah you're not
talking yeah good point having another
conversation all right let's let's back
outad of it then cuz we're probably I
want be the same all right okay I
watched The Conjuring last night oh
that's an all right movie yeah that's
the same thing actually with scary games
and scary movies same thing if you're
watching a scary movie with friends it
suddenly becomes like hilarious like
it's not doesn't have half the effect I
just make fun of everyone like if you
watch with a bunch of people is like the
dumbest thing in the world you watch on
your own it's terrifying yeah I yeah
horror movies by yourself they're almost
like too bad sometimes but I like them
all right I'm
done
cool next time we do the albino lby
stream we'll we'll just put you in a
dark room on your own how about that
yeah like how I uh grew up
let's let's uh let's swap over to a
different game what else you got on the
select screen there um right off the
bat uh unfortunately EV Valkyrie we
cannot play uh because of the output of
the game uh it breaks it because EV has
a weird output setting you can't see it
unless like I can only play it by myself
basically right uh Air Mac
command let's see what else is there
what else you
got uh does anyone else I'm actually not
quite sure how to library uh you might
you might have to pull off the Aus for a
second and click on do you have your
think there can't you uh press the Xbox
home
button say again I don't know can the
guys in the back see the actual menu
screen uh you should they should be able
to I think oh no actually I think
they're waiting uh I don't know if they
can see the the main menu yet so maybe
I'll just pick one of these you guys
can't see anything n okay oh so I just
I'll just start talking and saying or
listening these how how about that there
we are oh Kronos we could play Dead
secret
windlands
uh
Lucky's
tail I kind of feel like lucky tail
might be a good CH but what else what
else you got there airac do airac if you
done air yet uh that was the one I tried
a little bit it was actually kind of
tight yeah let's do defense grid to has
that same kind of overhead view it's a
cool like tabletop thing that
um of the 30 seconds I played was like
all right I'm into it like imagine XCOM
2 like you're just looking down on the
yeah did you ever see that DOTA sort of
visualization they did where they had
like a you could have a table in your
house yeah and basically the map would
play like like
toy
VR oh nice work look at that guy just
waved on him hey what's up buddy what's
his name I I don't know Micky blue blue
bot well don't just look at him Rob talk
to him to build your army yet it's
pretty intuitive but let's review it
anyway this is Microsoft s this is your
basically she's saying that I'm an
idiot so you're controlling the robot
that's correct okay sorry the robot on
the stream not the robot the one who the
one
who's the one who's walking around O
Okay ooh combat
zipper to build build something I'm
going to build a zipper cuz why
not
ooh okay I'll bu like commanding conquer
while floating above I love it the map
is that what's happening it's like I'm
Arnold
Schwarzenegger get it Jesus Christ what
is that game called again I don't know I
just can't stand those ass uh okay so
pick these things up
download you know me
Governor nice to see you nice to see you
find my
game so what are you controlling you
controlling the ship yes I'm I'm
controlling this uh you know little F14
here cool um and I'm imagining yeah I
mean I played a little bit of this so
it's like kind of like a strategy SL
like transformation AirMech to plane uh
where I'm going to drop these into
battle and kind of like you know do a
little combat plus uh unit management so
where be sure to grab at least two of
them oh I can do two at a time maybe no
maybe no what did she ask me to do oh
hold pilot inside you just suck them all
in with the to deploy your units with
the capture
command excellent they are moving into
position around the out go my children
that's pretty dope bring a few more
strategy from what do you like to
play you grow playing like Dune I grew
up with commanded conquer D yeah
starc I me starcraft's basically the
only you
can home world the home world was good I
mean it's not as oh I love home world
yeah home World deserts of K yeah that
was like a sort of surprise oh and um
what's it called ashes of the
singularity ashes of the singularity I
think just came out like really recently
or it's about to and oh look it's my
Nemesis
Natasha flip her off that's son but
ashes is the first RTS that makes use of
like quad core processors so you can
have insane amounts of units on it and
they're really detailed the world
themselves are like Planet well
not the eny this is cool as hell you
like this yeah I really do see it's like
you're sitting in front of a big table
like a toy kind of what we talking about
with the DOTA thing I guess yeah that's
I saying like if this was XCOM 2 and you
could just look down around the
battlefield yeah imagine if I was on a
VI and you could just like walk actually
like yeah right walk around the whole
thing I don't know if we have defense
grid too on this Oculus but they did the
same thing that was already a good game
to begin with I need this to move along
I I'm getting this what like I get it
yeah I know getting what do she want me
to do the Y button will activate the
smart camera I know we covered this wait
can you look up can you look up at
Natasha again quick
yeah no look at her
straight I'm sorry
what oh you guys are like making fun of
me right now don't worry about yeah I
know button will activate the smart
camera hold it down for a preview of
your pick up some units man do your
thing dude I what
is what am I doing
wrong why is this so funny can you just
help me out I'm doing the smart
camera sorry we're not even at all
looking at the gameplay I know you're
not what's what's the smart camera
what's going on I'm pushing why I I get
it I know how it operates I can't hear
him am I watching tradar park boys right
now
oh you're flying on the spaceship yeah
hit Y oh my
God the Y button will activate the smart
camera hold it down for a preview of
your faing directions you can also press
both shoulder butons at the same time to
quickly AC yes you don't actually you
don't actually have your headphones on
it's a we've had to Output it via the
television so oh okay this is pretty
cool too you can't hit me so were you
hitting y to swap the perspective like
that holding Y and then the uh right and
left buttons like basically put me third
person behind it so are you are you
making it Swap all the time like that or
is it doing no so I'm I'm turning I'm
I'm basically able to turn around my
position oh you're like rotating it I'm
rotating the whole map right okay like
in like 45 degree increments or
something is it if you want to manually
rotate the camera hold Y and then press
the left or right shoulder
buttons yeah they're really having to do
a lot of like teaching you how to
control the camera let's send your unit
I get it hold the B button and fly over
the units in front of your Fortress Yeah
suck them up now press up on the dpad to
command your units to attack the enemy
Fortress oh cool it's like one of the
next things with VR you hope they figure
out is the camera because you know we
take it for granted now it's usually
like a red analog stick thing on for how
many generations but and it was in the
previous game presumably as well you can
probably reset it's weird having the
like you've got this like manual control
over how you're looking but then you
also have the sort of the the Micro
Control of where you're glancing yeah I
mean that's different on the Vive
obviously because you're just like in
the space yeah or I guess it's different
with the Oculus touch as well so oh wow
imperum building oh look at that you're
like you're just going for it building
everything sure do you think you going
to attack what's her name again the
robot you're fighting Natasha Natasha
you think it's like a Hearthstone
element where you can like also just
like cast units at
her yeah I imagine so I mean I think I I
got to I got to you got to murder her at
the view of her base this is the
opposite of Battle Bots there are two
robots controlling what appear to be
humans humans yeah I actually didn't
figure out how gu is quite yeah okay
it's just right where I am okay
fine let's go my
children ooh that's tight oh that's
awesome okay so that's cool
f look up again oh yeah look at that now
we're talking Battlefield view she's
like go get him
rash
is that was cool that dude just morphed
into a helicopter yeah he can that's
what he's doing
too get in oh we're wrecking he's
controlling this one we're
wrecking go for
it I wish that damn blue guy would get
out of here it's just me Natasha dude
yeah third wheel yeah right he's like I
just I I just want to help that's all I
do here okay let's rate every game based
on an immersion scale out of 10 what was
the what was
albino how I don't even want to rate it
it's zero no okay honestly the Oculus
rifter Emer emersion scale right for
that was well at a
five this what about
this
[Laughter]
good luck all right eight
spot Victory this room is
sick this the room is my favorite part
for some reason I'm getting a very
OverWatch five you know oh
yeah cool what's it asking to do now oh
I know World War II airplanes you know
what this is that's a
P38 I love how he like he knows all
about the planes and nothing about the
robots yeah he was like a train pilot
yeah Rob was actually a
pil um what you guys think I'm enjoying
this uh do the chat or what you guys
think should we move on or maybe I could
play uh myriad's asking are there any
FPS games yet clearly just join the
stream should we uh try to find one of
those or let say let's say one more a
little bit of this what the button to
hell no he's just got that drive he's
got that pelvic thrust what's going on
there is this choosing your game mode
just go into a single player one and see
what you can do sure no go do
PVP oh yeah let's see if you can get
murdered oh oh thanks thanks for the
support there oh they've got dust oh
look at this this is this is great
everyone's favorite Counter-Strike map
is in this game
apparently
whoa
SI it's tight it's like those ass
aspects of the game don't come across at
all on streams like how weird it is to
like just look oh it's so side of
something
yeah yeah pick did you do that when you
were younger or when you first started
playing games like when you were trying
to look around corners and golden ey did
you actually physically yeah now you can
actually do it you remember when they
brought in the like the connect and they
were doing all that stuff they were
looing to the fact that you could do
that as well if like of course that was
all smoking mirrors yeah load of
bics you are you picking one or
searching for another player do that one
red room I mean it it's searching back
attive do a do a I can just do practice
loo chat saying go check out something
else all right fair enough I mean I
agree cuz I don't think I mean to me
this is fun but uh I'm not surprised
that this looks pretty dumb from
everyone else's
perspective at least you got to kill
Natasha I did I wrecked her yeah that's
great all right what else we
got what so do you project cars
installed say again do you have project
cars installed is that there maybe I see
it purchased I'm not sure if it's
installed
though CD project cars at of Warsaw C
project C cars SED project cars cars SED
what SED yeah I kep saying CD they
didn't like that at
all I really want to see Drift actually
as well yeah Marin Marin
Marin Mar chinwag marag Into the Dead
Into the Dead yeah yeah play it out it
looks like it looks I mean I'm assuming
it's a zombie game I want to see you get
into the dead I'm into
it all right you got put your goggles
back on no I'm I'm supposed to test and
make sure it works
zombies oh man
that's a lot of zombies yeah that was a
lot of zombies water are the
controls uh pause move
Center whoa slow down here o this is
tight wait the [__] did the fire just
disappear oh oh oh this is it I thought
I was like I thought it was an intro to
the
game oh new high score you supposed to
like Dodge them is this a I got run yeah
you just got to endlessly Sprint away
from zombies that's pretty that was a
fast run all right let's do
it there we go let's get that crop going
[__] cro it like a
hot I played a couple horror games of
GDC on the Vive
okay all right I got
now the thing with the perspective on
this is the the games render in their
own kind of different way so this one's
kind of more 4X three-ish I think
yeah what does this say equipping what
are you equipping uh a companion dog
okay more crates why not I guess these
are like intro perks let's turn them all
on you
know
whoa uh oh my what perk is that oh damn
this is a way Head Start
oh there's my
dog all right I get it now this is a
little this is tough so basically I'm
looking my my reticle is where I'm
looking and that's it and I oh [__] all
right why did you fly through time of
space that was really broke like not
going to lie that was super intense
you're never going to beat that score
that's
it that must have been one of the the
perks at the star here there okay all
right well you sp your coin SP your coin
D I just wasted all my coins all right
so your dog probably like kills one of
them or something right okay so it's
just a it's just like a side to side
thing oh good job dog it's a first
person bullet
Health shot thanks is it one shot one
kill or no I'm just hella
good yeah great
shot this is virtual reality coun balls
enjoyable what happens if you like run
into the side of a
wall yeah good point I'm not going to
try it out yet though got to beat your
high
scool dud my dog is tight I love the
idea that he's like imagine your
character's motion right now he's
sprinting and he's just holding this gun
at with this dumb look on his
face gotcha oh come
on like sprinting like full P
glitch his eyes like
roll all right let's try this one more
time CU what do you guys think hey
finding it sure oh wait did you just get
a chainsaw you guys need to tell me if
you're bored no it's all right it's good
stuff was that a chainsaw this quality
video game cont was that a chainsaw I
just could have sworn I saw a chainsaw
like in whatever menu was then oh as an
unlock oh is that what it
was check out the
Armory oh S I get more
dogs
Prince
Blitz dangerous what are the other dog
names keep
going Kyo do name is Kyo can you go
right and left I know someone who do Kyo
that's weird there we go
Titan ghost bloodthirsty
bloodthirsty nice okay so those are
their I guess their their
perks oh he's
dangerous what's your dog then my dog
miles Prince sofy is that what it says
Scrappy oh
Scrappy you know you know what that
means you get
it uh yeah rocket
launchers oh mission one to answer your
question like I got to complete mission
one in order to get that chainsaw okay
complete mission one rob you got it stop
[__] about and compl
Miss that's a really aggressive scream
that happens there we believe in
you is mission one that sounds like me
every morning light in the B you are
running at an outrageous Pace it's
really
good yeah the dog just like ate that
zombie was it just one intermittantly
clears your way so are you hitting left
or right as well to move I am I am
looking to shoot with uh the headset oh
[__] and I'm yeah I'm just doing uh side
to side step and that's it my my for
some reason I just I can't stop
[Laughter]
running fear has taken over it's just
like zombies I'm I'm
running I'm for scump from that day on
if I want to get somewhere I was
[Music]
running are you searching for Jenny
right now Jenny Jenny Jenny not we not
ping
carrots oh explosive
barrels
plus yeah get out of here uhoh I don't
like this corn children of Corin I don't
like this at all oh
whoa let's work that's like the scene
from signs she the lag move Swing Away
Rob hey what's my
mission uh oh bad time for reloading
yeah
more I love I love how you ended up in
the place where you started the last
time just put you there you almost did
it what's mission one see if you can
unlock the the speed up thing again did
you get
chainsaw nice yeah use it try and buy it
you probably have to play like 12 times
and do 16 microtransactions yeah
considering the last dog was what was it
like 40,000 coins or skull skull
coins is that what they're calling it
that's what they the has always been
skulls before the zombies came over a
grenade launcher would be fun okay how
many do I have oh wait can I just get it
I think I I already have I have it I
think I have it
guys great maybe it's I guess I guess I
have it unlocked cuz the pistol showed
up maybe red I think I have it yeah I
was going to say maybe it's a red flare
right
ooh okay so here oh I heard the missions
duh complete mission four to
unlock some St oh perks I guess I don't
know uh the zombies are closing in on
you kill as many zombies as you can
survive the night WEA the
storm okay that's cool so endless Runner
there's just like a like a hord mode and
then
there's
yeah you can do it should I uh I hope
you start with the chainsaw that would
be funny try to do the speed thing
again do speed one really should I I
it's like a [__] cheat do it how much
it cost all right let's do it use that
every time dude it's the I'm not going
to lie I don't like the intro of
it here we
go yeah I was to say how vulnerable do
you feel now I watched The Matrix last
night I knew you when I got home from LA
and you just did the thing where he
learned how kung fu stick the thing in
the back of his head he's
like yeah more I know
zombies I know I know
[__] no I don't like this oh my
God somebody said jumpack Joy Ride with
zombies yeah Jetpack Joy Ride remember
that yeah the hell out of that what look
at you oh look at if this land just
repeats the same level oh
really can you look behind can you like
why would I ever want to look behind cuz
then you you'll be like a
you'll be running you'll be running
backwards at incredible leg
speed dude back ping across can I get a
throw up bucket I want to see it yeah
that' be great okay are you ready well
the game even know what's going
on look behind look behind no no dude
get over
here all right I I got this in the bag
just on to like the next neighbor's Farm
there's even more zombies we don't have
any guns right now not yet look behind
look behind chainsaw chainsaw is it
yeah oh I love it oh yeah
see okay it's only good gas it's not
that chainsaw that s not much gas in
that chainsaw it's Snoop sold to that
guy at the start of season four The
Wire was that a chainsaw should we do
this how many more times it rings a bell
let's let's oh was a nail gun sh can I
which you want to play something else do
you want do you want to sit over here
you swap it out absolutely here what
time Scott coming on uh 15 from now two
I think so do you want to jump in did
you want to play a drift I can play a
drift you I think I think a drift would
be good these games are kind of been I
mean a drift will be cool for like 5
minutes and then you'll it'll be can I
have one go that one say what do you
mind if I have one go with that that one
oh yeah yeah yeah just let me jump in
show me wrong I'm like fascinated no I'm
sure I won't be better um but I'm just
like I want to like experience it you
know FYI this controller is
warm and moist taking off my mic here I
don't know what it is but it's really
wet it wasn't me oh dude the the robot's
been trying to knock my coffee
[Laughter]
over that's genius wait where the game
where's what the controller here
is let you put this microphone on shut
up
you is it the right okay
I you look like a mad
scientist what was that don't worry you
just did all right it would have been
really embarrassing if I was wearing the
shirt right now on the stream I got
Oculus hair we can't hear you start I'm
going do the Head Start thing repeat
that joke once I put your mic on oh jeez
what no no Che the out uh trigger left
trigger is uh reset the
[Applause]
image oh my God this
go where give me a gun do I have to jump
he just jumps automatically it's just
left uh left stick side to side and uh
this is amazing your Oculus this is like
when you're oh Lord there's my hair oh
yeah here we go what is it red Trigger
or something all right you got it
shouldn't have used it loing up that
precious gas you this is like you know
you're like in the rush to get to like
the bus and there's a group of school
kids in front of you on the path and
you're like trying to like find your way
past them what school did you go
to no like as an adult or like you're in
a grocery store and there's a bunch of
people where who are just taking the
godamn time and you're like trying to
get past them or just anyone in San
Francisco no one walks in normal speed
here no no one has anywhere to be here
right it's annoying I've only got one
gas
left how do you know that just from
timing it yeah in the background it says
it over there see they're like one oh
God the flashing like super in the
distance I was just looking at the
zombies got the green one there you go
this is kind of cool what's this oh [__]
I don't even want this yeah I
know I want the other one back I'm all
sweaty it's just
corn I'm corn and
tolerant it's a real
thing I'm going to dump on this guy a it
it give me a I I I feel like by moving
your head you get that like that just a
little leeway with like getting around
zombies like while he was using the
stick got it damn what if he
accidentally just like cut the beams on
the building
and these birds are freaking out
freaking oh [__] yeah he didn't even
need to fill the gun up he just dump
down this is surprisingly kind of all
right like granted it's only the first
it looks decent it's like Dam there
[__] gotcha I will say the them eating
you animation is awful it's so bad sick
look at all that it it should be like an
alien isolation move you know like they
like grab your stomach and like rip it
out and eat it in front of you and it's
like a 30 minute animation minutes those
ones are very long those ones were like
yeah they weren or it actually just all
right do you want to get in here for a
drift is that it sure is exit to home
got a few minutes all
right hey what's up
robot that was
cool all right I mean so far the only
one I like would want to play for an
extended period of time has been that
air one you know like I D Chronos the
one on
that yeah Kronos uh is is cool I drift
all right Michael
mahardy reviewer of a drift five out of
10 on games.com you sort of jokingly
said were you saying dakus version was
better or or not as good is better well
it's doesn't look as good but it's more
fun to play
right oh that's my phone thanks forgot I
fruit thank you I fruit that's
right if I found that if I found that
phone somewhere and saw it had ey fruit
on it I would have been like that's
robs that's that's cool you run strong
with GTA I do when I flew down La
yesterday I realized that I put like
Grand Theft Auto 5 stickers on my
luggage so it had like a banshee sticker
on it for like the car and what's what's
the San what's the name of the county
not San Andreas no the uh uh the one up
north oh [__] for in in GTA five five
yeah there's another name s um whatever
that is Sandy uh Shores oh yeah you're
right but it's not that it's something
else all right but yeah they they had
that cool cool what sup Mike up all
right whoa where are you dude what the
[__] are you doing Mike are you are you
playing this game
yeah wait is not sh up is this a drift
it drifts great put your hands in the
air put your hands in the air just trust
me both hands put both hands in the air
okay yeah he's got great muscles
actually you're you're right you're
right on AR put that down just one arm
up yeah just one yeah that's good yeah
yeah what and then could you just start
in a in like two seconds could you just
screaming scream
just keep going keep going keep going
who is that is it showing up that uh no
you're doing great you're doing
[Laughter]
great
a drift looks really different on
VR I see what's happening Mike now
imagine you're C paited I can't
[Laughter]
go all right all right drift yeah play
drift yeah yeah start off a new game all
right drift with us the best part of I
thought whole oh no should I start from
no I don't want to spoil
anything yeah don't yeah don't spoil it
spoil the
um is this the start of the game yeah
it's a little like room you float
around it's like it's a the G this game
is about like a space station breaking
up or something it's gravity kind of
what is it's a it's a real shame that
the um baffling that just fell off the
wall didn't happen during your
time people watch it you can't see but
we have some uh sound styrofoam
cushioning the walls and that's what
that's what fell down Mike
something fell yeah it fell right near
you and it was a shame it didn't hit
your head Eric T's in there now going
like [__] I glued those to the walls
like three of them just fell in not well
enough oh I who inverted this uh oh no
was Chris Waters playing oh what a let
me do that really quick oh the last
person was playing Mary is like having
to do so much work to like re right so
that's that's an issue with these games
is like the output like all right we're
good isn't always 16 9 or something
preferable so like we it's like you know
two lenses as in both eyes so she has to
like basically crop everything out and
scale it soccer
ball oh
header head
it oh I guess you can't because you're
like your head's inside of the suit
right yeah look down look
down describe what we're looking at Mike
it appears to be some sort of Planet I
don't know what system this is in hold
on
perform
e dude those googly
eyes oh it's uh the souls that that must
be Earth the soul did you just say it's
the soul dude you're Ador the moon the
Milky the Milky Way uh oh they want me
to boost oh desend here we go get a
little glance down at the Earth kind of
far back in this chair can you figure
out where we are what are we floating
over right now we are it's the Han for
space station okay no I'm serious I mean
like where I'm not familiar with that I
mean like where over the Earth we are oh
yeah conon wise okay continent wise
where are we continent wise that looks
like Spain like Europe right there yeah
Spain Portugal right there cool I think
I don't know I failed geography could
you uh point out Madrid for us please oh
man this is what this is what makes some
people not feel well right yeah I have
to admit it's not the best feeling so
what are you controlling are you are you
controlling like every pitch the uh to
move the actual helmet I'm using the
right analog stick but to look around
from inside the helmets me right but are
you moving your character as well like
were you rotating this is Boost this is
Ascend
descend okay and then this like writes
you so you know like what is you bring
your sight back on like an x-axis kind
of where's the button to imagine George
CL
let's make him up here hit that soccer
ball again any fire extinguish engage
football radar to our European viewers
in Madrid I wonder how much ad Revenue
they got for that soccer ball what did
it say it look like a like a
brandir
Adidas why is it going to Black like
that that's like that that's when you
write it like a readjust your her pitch
or something Matas says good job
actually is Europe oh is it great job
Mike you did pass it's pretty cool later
in the game when you're on the dark side
of the Earth or uh yeah Dark Side the
dark side well you mean like Russia yeah
you're like over Asia later on it's
pretty
gorgeous you all right Mike you you're
see stressed no it's I'm sitting up so
I'm I don't know when I was leaning back
I was falling into the helmet so I'm
sitting up now and it's my back is so
your face is coming out of the helmet on
the other side
2037 how old would you be in
2037 uh Survivor 45 nice no that's not
true
whatsoever 46
56 56 sorry yeah 56 no 46 uh a bunch of
people who are in the chat have actually
like pre-ordered their Oculus and
they're using this to like satiate
themselves until they
arrives waa oh this is stressful why did
that
happen
oh well that's so right now I'm actually
getting a pretty huge sense of vertigo
stressed
out what are you got getting vertigo you
feeling a little bit yeah it has a good
sense
of height oh oh
man did you crack did you crack your
yeah the thing is later in the game you
can just tap a wall and it'll start
cracking your helmet really oh as in
like a health system is basically that
yeah and then there there's oxygen you
see my oxygen level right down here
right did we did we miss something that
like everything is it no it's a it's
like a jump cut oh okay a jump cut not
that's not the proper term it cut like
so that refills your oxygen there's a
lot of those everywhere as you can see
there an abundance of them oh yeah so
I'm holding it's weird to get used to
you hold X to reach out your arm but
then you still have to it kind of guides
you toward it so you still have to
actually like push yourself forward to
make contact with whatever you're trying
to grab so that's locked on but I still
have to actually grab
it all right
so going over here so that's what gets
frustrating later on too when you're in
Parts when there are multiple hallways
stacked on top of each other the radar
right here doesn't really indicate what
ele you're going for right so
yeah
what it's a twitch robot look you're on
camera go to let
robot.txt I love how every time you come
in it's like better in a whole new way
like so much was it was it wired at one
stage as well was it always Wireless
yeah it's incredible like all these
massive lithium batteries on it like
motherboard in there it's able to like
climb over stuff real good now as well a
little better so bright work on cords c
yeah yeah good Cable Management
happening here oh work on climbing oh
climbing over cords oh yeah there there
are some challenges in this room that's
for sure
those googly eyes Mike you're doing wait
yeah you're doing great oh here we go so
it's all busted
up busted up oh jeez my oxygen is L I
forgot to breathe you're you're in Li of
oxygen oh it looks real bad what so what
what's the premise we went from like a
fairly nice space station to uh they
explain what happens later
that's part what's what that the game is
kind of looking for survivors and
figuring out what happened some like
having a cigarette or some [__] like
that yeah I hope it was something really
benign yeah like like somebody flushed a
toilet and it just
like [__] oh I hit two when I only had a
one so I could go I'm just going to you
could go for it go to oh go for it go
home dude where are you now yeah haven't
you seen gravity she just okay maybe not
now you can after I'll try oh you can
after what happens you burn up uh no you
just you don't get far enough before
your oxygen Runs Out oxygen is rarely a
problem if you're just going along the
path yes but when you're trying to like
move something when you're trying to
kill yourself whatever it is a hindrance
probably not 10,000 miles here we go
whoa here we go
whoa so
this this this what you guys were doing
yeah all right now I can like get that
oxy get that oxygen so where do you want
to go right now where on Earth our
audience is really getting a grasp of
what
this oh is going toit it's empty it's
empty oh it's that th how what's space
like
Mike um tell us pretty
big it's a lot of is that corn flakes
somebody was had a bowl of cereal and it
just
there appear to be Doritos scattered oh
Doritos the Cool Ranch the real flavor
don't give me any of that cheese [__]
what yeah I said it Bob Jones 9 says
Mike has perfect
face there you go well you heard hair
first those eyes are very similar to his
yeah actually you can't even tell the
difference you kind I I didn't even know
he was wearing so you go to most of
these places like you see right now
throughout the 6 hours it takes you
tell me if we should
uh no we're having a great time don't
worry I'm enjoying
this it's very much actually like the
story of gravity Alex osima osima osima
what I'm you're Alex oima she's kind
of I don't know she's kind of
responsible for are you reviewing
gravity right now on our stream o let's
get this give gravity out of 10 Gravity
the movie out of 10 yeah uh is a drift
better or worse than gravity oh uh
worse could you just look behind you I
think George Clooney is behind
you o that
readjusted that's not
good what
the there we go Mike can you uh fix like
like like raise your hand like you're
fixing something right in front of
you sure what is
happening the back button's not doing
its thing yeah we can see yeah let
me
something's where's the
uh what's it like being in space is it
is it does it feel Majestic there we go
does it feel peaceful is it stressful
floating around space peaceful I think
it would feel more peaceful if I could
hear through the headphones as opposed
to the stream right but yeah it's nice
it's uh do you ever look at the planet
Earth and just
think wow that's the funny thing like
you think you think it would connect you
to like Humanity on a bigger level but I
just feel lonely having overview effect
oh really yeah well little water
droplets whoa whoa that was the you can
do that
again okay did you look above just look
up for a second what what country is
that uh appears to be
Singapore like I want you to start
panicking uhhuh yeah is this a screen
test you just give us more of that this
is audition reel could you do the screen
but just with like a with an
accent ah
get some oxygen it's wonderful this is
wonderful entertainment for the whole
family oh [__] this this is locked it's
locked I know you just unlock it unlock
it it's the belt you got to help them
Mike help them help them open the
station is falling apart oh my
god do your best like spinning sickness
motion whoa she almost grabbed
you yeah more of that do more of that
reach out reach out to Sandra's arms uh
Mike there's a movie being played behind
you can
you can you uh not describe it uh is it
gravity
no that's a so that's a drift yeah right
there I'm going to you can oh I
was yep look behind
you I have no clue what's going
on Perfect all right Neil the grass
Tyson all right okay well that
was so so what's happening again sorry
Mike we we missed that what's going you
I'm just repairing vital systems
throughout the ship and trying to figure
out what's happen in happen in yeah you
I could go and read like my this is my
quarters right just hang out yeah it's
waited at wait at the apocalypse are you
ever doing anything cool other than just
drifting uh
you get a boost later on you're fixing
the station but it's four big identical
side quests uh fetch quests okay you
read all this stuff the writing is
actually pretty good in all these if you
take the time to go through it obviously
I didn't this
time it's good writing good for skipping
like you with the notes yeah hell no all
right okay
readjust all right thanks so much Mike
are you yeah for showing us a drift cool
yeah I think all right my favorite part
was the part where George Clooney had a
conversation with Sandra
b it's really good H not just available
in virtual reality you can also play
drift on a regular ass computer this is
true are we getting Scotty in here I
think so let's do it can I have it Go in
office again hell yeah yay let's do it I
don't have to tell you get in there go
go a drift there you go what's up Scott
hello are you going to take a turn in
the VR dream machine
speaking loudly you're out see you later
bro hey Scott how are
you whoa tagging in tagging in what you
been up to today I have been just
editing millions of things I should put
the mic on first I should have asked you
the question before it's okay I should
have realized I was holding the mic
instead of answering your question
nice uh also t-shirts are kind of the
worst for microphones I'm just going to
do this they are like if you got the
placket if you can like plug it in on
that that is way easier than a t-shirt
it's why I normally wear a a some sort
of colored I assume it because you were
just just fancy you're a high class man
classy gentlemen sure uh I'm going to
try some of the 360 video things okay oh
yeah just like the experiential yeah
I've heard that they're really
good so can you guys see this do you
want to play guess what's on the green
screen should be able to see it looks
like I
can I'll give you a hint it rhymes with
yanu Mary's got Mary's showing something
different at the moment there is no
spoon all right England football team is
what it says here taking neverbe seen
look inside Wembley Stadium thanks to FV
that's the Football Association
television 360° video from England's
clash with the
Netherlands I don't I have no idea if
this is going to work or not
uh I mean we can see it kind of can you
see yes we can see you're in a locker
room okay there's a there's a man
picking up jerseys can you are you guys
seeing it as I turn my head oh yeah yeah
yeah we're seeing what you're seeing is
it also in like
240p yeah it looks it is a very beige
innocuous locker room yeah this is the
world's most boring locker room does it
smell yeah is the can who the [__] oh he
just appeared he did
do soccer players not materialize in
real life is that I looked down and then
I looked up and I was in a different
place uh you yes you are in a different
place fun so far can I check what's on
this guy's phone this is this is
riveting it's is feel like we're we're
right there with him this is part of
part of socer History Rob oh God he
looks like a oh Jesus here I am look at
all warped again that that seems to be
scaring you Danny the cuts and video
It's upsetting especially when
then have Wayne Rooney walking to oh
look it's Ste
walos this is amazing he knows these
people are I've been in the stadium I've
been I've been over there so it's not
quite as never before seen as the
opening text in gled I mean i' I've
never stood in the middle of the stage
look at
that I was here for an American football
game before I mean this would probably
be really cool if it wasn't shot on a
crap on a goddamn DV cam this footage
appears to be higher res than the locker
room footage although I'm maybe that's
just the monitor we're watching on I
don't know it's yeah well I mean it
isn't isn't that isn't that how 3D or
360 cameras like have to be it's like
some sort of like low res function there
are some pretty good one you get those
ones with the sticks that like balls on
sticks all right hey what's up guys high
five high five anyone n anyone Wayne or
I kind of you need the motion
controllers to high five so you got to
yeah
no make sure you get the I about this
guy Theo you didn't get picked today
Danny Roy
[Music]
Hudson so those are the Roy Hudson's
face got all like right so those were
the images are connecting
right
yeah this is I can see her notes a
little dumb it says [__]
hm I like how annoyed she looks by the
she she was clearly standing next to an
actual camera person and was just like
why are you here I I just got walked
through by a bunch of Dutch
children can relate yeah I know I know
feeling on a scale for when you immersed
how immersed are you look at this guy I
hope he like scratches his
junk I'm watching you [__] see I
feel like this 360 experience would work
really well in something that you
couldn't experience in real life like if
you're standing in the middle of a
volcano that might be kind of cool if
you're like standing underwater I mean
this is pretty cool yeah okay I mean hey
I'm not in there with you I just feel
like this is such a like a I don't know
yeah you're F you've been to a you've
been to a soccer match before like let's
try you never been on the sideline but
this is like we'll try one of the other
ones cuz there's a whole like yeah yeah
look at this
guy hey what's up I mean I don't know if
you were just a die hard football fan
I'm enough that you guys kind of see
this right we can actually you can
Oculus video so which one should I Star
Wars oh that yeah that seems like the
obvious choice let's do it
uhhuh oh yeah hey this is see this is
more interesting can you walk around no
it's all video no it's video I'm inside
the willennium Falcon damn
it can you believe we're only 16 years
into the willennium God damn
it so much more to go long road ahead of
guys is this it is something going to
happen
it dude I thought the point of video is
that it was in motion yeah well I'm
surprised you can't actually like sit in
no controls pilot seats nope you're just
like hanging out in the middle of the
cockpit okay disgustingly filthy this
what the [__] happened here I mean it's
so
chewbaca cheac the characters they're
not really going to be cleaning upaca
God damn it Chewbacca my God you filthy
animal did you have a
curry chewbaca had a Chewbacca in his
Curry he had a chicken Cora and look
what happened well this would be tight
if this was interactive like I could you
could totally make a
feasible you know uh William Falcon and
just walk around in every area I'm very
curious to see what PlayStation does
with Battlefront cuz like they're doing
the exclusive psvr Battlefront
experience which we know nothing about
but they announced during GDC that'll be
really cool hopefully uh I'm guessing
you'll be able to like maneuver around
and do stuff in that one mhm we see one
would hope expect hope I'm just hanging
it in DC yeah Cherry Blossom's real nice
I was again rather bizarrely I was here
about three months ago at Martin Luther
King does this does this match with how
does this compared I me to the real to
the genuine article I remember the real
version of DC having better resolution
than this is it as lame in real life
yeah it's like it's interesting enough
oh just like my real trip to DC The
Weather Channel logo appear
to welcome hope you enjoyed it this is
so good this is most immersive weather
yeah what am I going to this is Josh
Gates and as the host of expedition
unknown I do a lot of no idea what this
is I'm in this guy's [__]
bag yeah you are you're in his bag why
why what the [__] what
sorry he's got a knife he's got to cut
me I mean don't worry you're safe safe
with us
Danny seriously are you kid why would
you film this from the perspective of
like what a traveling gnome and a bat I
don't understand this is great ever
watch those those grocery haul videos no
so grocery Hall so on no Hall h h so
there these videos on YouTube where it's
basically just like soccer moms like
emptying their their like Supermarket
like holes like they went and it's
basically about like so that other like
Homemakers wherever they are can like
look at these videos and be like oh yeah
Cheerios and the milk and then you get
the it's like so they can figure out
well Jesus put your hands away from me
[__] so maybe the future of
grocery videos is that like people
opening bags of groceries but they have
one of these things you can just sit on
the kitchen counter you going to cut me
sorry I'm not sold yeah I'm got to say
well I'm not sold on like the 2D version
of what Danny's describing so I don't
know that it really needs to be more
immersive but this looks like more like
a kidnapping
video there was a definite Ransom vibe
to like the black just trying a darkened
room with like harsh overhead lighting
right he's just trying to sell you
where's the
girl all right ooh I'm digging this okay
this is better I do love an aurora balis
yeah just fun fun thing to say Aurora
balis steamed
hams what's going on over there oh I
don't like the fact that it's in it's in
Fast Forward oh it's like that zombie
game
again where's my shotgun guess because
you can't fast forward life they're just
doing it for you that's I don't like
that either I'm it's like I'm wasting
days all right that's [__] what else is
that what's this
one like put me in like a right like
something weird right like put me in the
middle of like Rio Carnival or something
the fast foring is [__] like a drug
deal gone bad or like a particularly
nasty Family Feud like something that's
like right the P where where the hell am
I who no don't do that don't do that oh
God feeling weird what the whoa
who see this is kind of what you're
describing you're in the middle of a
band huddle I
think oh God my you're now it's it's
become Guitar Hero live minus Guitar
Hero Danny you're
[Applause]
live player instrument dude I don't know
what this is it's two
drummers but this okay this is oh you're
a bouncer Danny this is what we were
asking for when's the main act coming
on yeah I'm like I'm like I'm I'm here
to like carry pit like exactly Crow
Surfers drunk girl safety from behind
the yeah hey what's up
hey are you Union look at this guy whoa
[Music]
whoa you're all here why are you
recording on your phones oh dude I I
agree that is a you'll never watch that
video cool that's uncomfortable that
actually seems kind of cool Jesus why am
I on this guy's head there's a uh have
you guys played budget cuts at all no
budget cuts is a a VR game where [__]
what Danny just did is kind of a
built-in mechanic like you can lean over
the edge of like a raised platform and
look down see what's beneath you it's
like a part of a sort of stealth
mechanic um so it's not just like look
at the vertigo of there's stuff beneath
you it's actually like a gameplay
mechanic it's pretty cool uh I think I
saw one I don't know if this was part of
the same game but it was like you save
this cat yeah is that part of it or no
different different experience um yeah
been that one uh I don't know it's been
like all over the internet
cple days which I haven't played that
one but it seems like a cool idea yeah I
mean as someone who like I feel like the
older I get the more progressively more
scared I get of like heights but like
you're basically you're on a board and
we run out of large
shirts you are you working tonight hey
what's up uh but yeah you basically like
walk a plank and you're on a you know
the 100th floor of skyscraper try to
pick up a cat it's just
like yeah I will say that VR does
communicate scale in a way that that
traditional games can't so even
something as simple as like oh you're
standing yeah oh she definitely yeah
girl in the black top yeah she's
absolutely not in music oh yeah confetti
it just what oh the confetti broke the
game is this stream I think life is
lagging out is this Quantum break I
guess this must be streaming I guess are
you pausing it what's going on reality
is breaking yeah Danny the background is
changed
now is it gone
uh we don't know because uh we're now
watching the Village People okay Danny
do you know the
YMCA oh the young men Christian
Association uh this would be a great
time to remember how the lyrics of that
song went so I can make a joke but I
honestly don't remember anything besides
the chorus young man that's well okay
yeah oh I found more better ones I found
better ones all right they were on 36
those let's see it listen you do that
we're can you watch the Village People
YC music video I'm going to hang out
with my my boy Bono oh yeah who doesn't
love Bono as we or as we call him back
home in in Era Bono oh hey The Edge I
can't tell if that was a dig or if
that's actually what people call oh
that's the edge right what's up the
edge I wonder if that was a
self-assigned nickname or people
actually refer to him cuz like I can't
imagine other people being like hey man
I'm to call you the edge yeah you know
feel like that had to have been
something he just decided to do hey guys
you watching this I am dude this is the
first video so far Danny where
everyone's looking at you what do you do
it's almost a little creepy actually
what do you do bro he holds a base why
am I even here this this is supposed to
be intimate isn't it feels intimate like
there's singing to Bono is singing
directly into my
[Music]
soul you have a lot more instruments
than the other three good call it's true
what what the the Ed just turned into an
Asian man
no he was always there oh no sorry he's
native American now I feel awful Bono
just turned into a sofa with Jacob har
face
onest it's a really uh Progressive sofa
oh look a the drummer turned into a dog
that's clearly better than a
drummer yeah I don't understand why the
world is like fading in and out of
different scenes this is really strange
you're now in my grand a 90-year-old
living room yes oh hey sweet
harp
this is uh I don't have much you're now
in Paris apparently I've been I've been
informed I would love for it to fade
into someone like God oh my God did you
see that cat the cat was not into it the
cat was like that cat must got lost in
this white room so often hey what's up
what are you doing in my
house I have to say it is fun watching
Danny turn his head towards nothing so
yeah you slow
and we're back to Bono come full circle
this would be pretty cool if it wasn't
in like SD yeah is I mean that is a
shame that the image quality is so low
the resolution is so
low should we are you guys getting bored
of this cuz I can do this all day this
stuff is so weird um I would I don't
know I would say maybe go back to games
unless you can find something that's
kind of interesting see this might be
cool oh yeah alley Rob wants this got
high hopes for this I'm theing officer
FL leader of your us Blue Angels let's
do it
guys is it necessary for you guys to
take off this
close absolutely
information we do that hopefully to why
is somebody
commentating this isn't like aircom this
is just a guy talking about oh my God
this is insane that's dumb so you're
telling me it's like probably a Blue
Angel like in a post interview like
describing what you're they're doing
that does seem a little unnecessary it's
already cool dude there's yeah listen wa
they got close man they get so close
they do this is awesome this is actually
really cool can you look all the way
behind you Danny our first maneuver with
oh nice okay this is the first this is
the first one where I'm actually like
there's no way you could really
experience this in real life so this is
actually kind of awesome right well I
mean not there's no way you could
experience this h i mean short of like a
couple decades of like military
experience if I'm sure well yeah
had I'd say like two grand he'd probably
do it you think yeah I mean these guys
fly all the time they I feel like you
get like like the budget you could
probably get like the red or white
Angels but I don't what the blue they're
like top of the line they're
who that's tght this is very cool
actually Danny are you experiencing any
vertigo at all like does it feel like or
no no but I just had this like
overwhelming like desire for them to
just start like shooting missiles
at the houses there dude cockpit games
really are kind of the most natural fit
for VR in a lot of ways you're so close
that's pretty crazy all right one more
all right I could have done what is this
thing it's a shame you can't randomize
it you just do like 3D experience
roulette that is not a
shame that's a a Showtime boxing I can
get punched in the face that could be
good we went through a lot of lenses can
I see twitch wait a second
wait a second oh this is kind of cool I
have a feeling I know you're I know
exactly what you're doing can we search
I don't so I'm excited to see where this
is going search on this he's gonna he's
I don't know it's get it's going to get
weird if he does it we search is there
search setting on this twitch search are
you looking up uh X Games spot
Josh no you see this in stream though
he's gonna I mean it's right there Danny
to the left did you see it yeah go down
you had it
go left lane go down yeah down down down
that one right oh hey oh are we going to
Inception this this going to get real
weird Cinema oh how do you want to view
gam spot home uh oh oh no oh no this is
oh this is bad what else we got Cinema
and theater the moon yeah dude Moon
let's got I'm theater in oh no this is
gonna get really crazy I'm just sitting
on
my look at the screen look at the screen
you got to keep looking at the
[Applause]
screen oh no can we go
deeper let's just do it yeah hey Rob how
are you how you doing yes
we looking good
Rob where is the VR porn says Captain
smug oh yeah you can read the comments
on like a two-minute
Del this is really awful hey how are you
good how are
[Music]
you thanks man you're looking pretty
good
too oh my goodness oh let's go I want to
go see the moon a delay let's do it this
is great this looks great we're now
mostly getting Danny's googly eyes this
is
amazing oh look it's the lunar land the
Earth is not that close to the Moon oh
you know pretty close ridiculous oh my
God what else we got what else we got
the
void oh I don't like this at all this is
whoa who this is
uncomfortable do you feel any
existential dread seeping in or yeah VR
is is awful and we need to burn it down
this is this is so upsetting it's over
before it even begins one more yeah get
punched in the
face that was all right this could be
cool oh nope why do everything not cool
fast forward I'll just I'll do what I do
at most uh boxing highlights and oh it's
not from the perspective of one of the
boxers that defeats the whole purpose
I'll do what I do at most of these and
just try and Skip forward to The
Knockout good
call oh uh no you you get no
control oh
[Applause]
oh that one large man punched the other
large man enough times look at this oh
disaster right oh and he's got a exit
move that counter right hook let's get
in
slowmo he tight look at these guys oh
the commentators you can hear
them yeah what's up high
five everyone immediately around the
ring is not excited to be there they see
it all the
time that girl you tried to go for a
high five absolutely did loser that M
high five is commemorated forever in a
special turns around oh go right he
turns around and like looks around
because he knows everyone behind him
just saw yeah literally millions of
people oh watch that in real time and
also people in the future and virtual
reality were standing right beside him
the whole time this is so weird
okay yeah well good times I'm sorry a
little more hey Giant Pizza all right a
we need that for our office all right
look it's an emoji now I think this is
what we really
need this is the this is something this
is something I'd probably do all day
yeah if you could have like if you could
do a live webcam of like your dog at
home and then like strap on an Oculus
and like be hanging out with your dog or
like 12 puppies at while at work that'd
be pretty great
this yeah I'm into this can you hear
them Danny can you hear these puppies
can you pet
them maybe they're all
mutes mutes don't make noises malam
mutes hey shorts a dog okay breed I like
it yep Oh there's a lot of stuff here
this is actually kind of cool movies
what do you got you have a lot of
options yeah what you looking at we
can't see shorts
lunar I'll try stream this oh no it's
just our movie sorry forget that forget
that
all
right well that was that was all right
that video stuff was all right it's good
to explore the other options outside of
just games I I feel like this is a lot
of the stuff that people may not be as
familiar with if they're you know
considering buying an Oculus yeah you
can also get access to a bunch of
weird 360p videos that's that's the
thing right like I yeah we get it we we
already know what you're not supposed to
do like just imagine like you know down
the road from me your from now where
people have figured out that formula
where it's like yeah you know warp to a
live city and see a 360 like image of it
high quality it' be like that'd be cool
around the GL Google Maps done like
that's that's cool as
hell what do you guys think I should
play I think we should see some games I
you know we don't we don't have the chat
around us uh there's that yeah hey chat
the the body VR is here which I've never
heard of I haven't heard of that either
actually educational virtual reality
experience have you guys played EV
Valkyrie yet on the stream no we can't
we can't really unfortunately because
the output in order to live stream it
would it just breaks the game because of
the the bummer okay never mind let's go
for I'm going to go for lost figured
that might be good since the packing
which hopefully this is a video game and
not the television show Lost stand up
for best
viewing uh oh I don't think I'll be
doing that one of the most frustrating
shows of all time
uh-oh uh-oh are you going to stand up uh
I don't think I'll stand up I got I
think I'm all
right sit down for other viewing
ooh you guys seeing this we are we are
it's not VR I think we're back inside of
a
uh a studio oh H here we
go can you are you like centered I am
now I'm not moving you
whoa hey what's up
buddy o it's a bug it's like a little uh
bug it looks like a
fan it's a what do you call those things
like a firefly yeah
ooh good job good job name of that bug
Rob that's a good bug name look at that
good job way to go Bud I know my bugs
hey what's up buddy this is
cool can tell you holding the controller
you ooh oh we're still doing the intro
Oculus
presents well this is this is
ailc oh an Oculus story I got to reach
around to see the is there 3D audio does
it feel like or is it hearing like
spatially so unfortunately we have to
Output the headphones uh directly to the
stream so he can't experience the w w
sus kuchka unsell nice created this
lost lower case not pennies
about oh hello birdie that was
bird can you move
nope this is me playing the video game
can you do anything besides
look what is what is beeping something's
beeping did hear did
hear yes okay is that tree
beeping do you have some sort of motion
tracker actually a cell
tower
loading screen stand up for
best it's really upset with you for not
standing are we back at the start again
oh my god oh I guess I pressed the
restart button oh no well well that's
that I'm not I'm not seeing that damn
bug again let's let's try something else
it seems like a try not an amazing
design decision to have a a button that
just starts everything over I wasn't
using the right controller and I I
didn't do it before so oh right ooh VR
tennis online
that might be
fun is it like we is it motion control I
guess we don't have yeah there's no
touch yet never mind right yep take it
back totally take it back colop we can
see the chat again though insect
simulator question marks all right here
we
are cool what a great background there
we go hey what's up oh well that's an
interesting female character you don't
like
that yeah I don't think that's how
Serena Williams plays video game to be
completely honest all right key where's
the any key I'm logged in as PC
brand he won't mind this is a really I'm
going to try and play online straight
away ranked match sorry pet dang dude
really no fear whoa Danny
whoa y yes absolutely should I go for
Electro snake or tornado
tornado see see it'sa you probably say
either way honestly
yeah I guess I got both even better
ready nope uhuh I am oh
man uh oh is yes I'm hoping the loading
screen is a pra like this is oh it takes
you to a like practice mode as you earn
a holding pattern during matchmaking
that would actually be really smart
assuming that's what's happening I don't
know though whoa who you got the first
one you got the first
couple hey okay it plays like every
tennis game I've ever played so there's
that can I where's the like slam button
oh it's green okay that's cool you got
you got to do it based on the color of
the reticle ah timing of it's I feel
like this should really be in first
person like the fact that it's third
person undermines the whole kind of
point of VR a little bit actually
yeah ooh hook shot baby take that you
dumb
Android see if you can hit those hot air
balloons up
there yeah
right they might be out of bounds but
you know is this me oh this is me
waiting to play okay I get it okay so
yeah yeah searching for opponent yeah I
mean how many other Oculus owners right
now want to play a tennis game probably
not a whole lot uh maybe one especially
against our friend Titan here hey chat
somebody has an Oculus and you want to
play against Danny go ahead and jump
online right now sup Titan baby dang my
favorite thing about Titan is head is
hair looks like the top of a cake look
that man he's also glowing he's
ripped never ski L
day oh
no oh did you quit sure did let's play
against the let's play against the
artificial yeah intelligence single game
probably a good
Titan yeah I want to play cha was his
name Chaw I can't remember cha Gia sure
done like his hair Anita Enzo oo Enzo H
I like that Mike mahar's hair is like
the exact opposite of wearing a VR
headset like it goes up in the middle
but then when he has the headset on just
pulls it all
down so yeah it's the it's right down
down the uh the yeah inverse Mohawk
going yeah here we
go I'm playing
Mercury Sailor Mercury or just give me
your best shot robot
Lady this is
fun this is fun I'm having
fun sorry folks I'll do
I'm going to yeah on hit me here go on
the Running Animation is
perfect uh yeah you definitely don't
move forward nearly as much as you
should for the way that stride looks I
mean you're not let come off the
Baseline usually
but they don't care listen you're
playing against a robot I think all bets
are
off come back here Titan this is the
secret Blizzard game that we never got
to see like does this look even benefit
in any way like there is basically no
reason I'm playing this on right like
it's just other than actually looking
around like that's kind of cool which
after a nice hit which I was basically
doing in the Wembley Stadium demo
earlier yeah it's
true but the difference is this crowd
doesn't move I'm really having a problem
judging the depth cuz I keep thinking
it's where I am and not where he is so I
keep it's virtual reality you're
supposed to be there oh oh wow Who let
that blimp play nice very distracting
blimp good recovery
though well okay that was cool that was
all right only in virtual reality Danny
we're trying to play a sport here get
off the court change
ends oh oh thank
[Music]
you
oh [__] you I would commentate if I knew
more about tennis but I don't know about
tennis yeah yeah should we swap should
we swap it out is there we we do one
more game maybe and I'll swap swap it
out sure sure sure what else is there
here Oculus dream deck that sounds all
right oh project cars is it installed I
don't know if it is uh it says purchase
not installed yeah you're right you
could hit install and let it install and
play something else yeah I could
especially Jeff is currently playing
Project CARS right now is he like dman
that Jeff yeah he's playing apparently
dude yeah we should absolutely just join
I don't think I can actually do that I
don't think you can install from here I
don't know got check out the store maybe
that's where I download move on all
right give me give me one sec I'll see
if I can I can install it real quick V
installed Blaze Rush that sounds like a
video game title if one Blaze Rush
that's like when a sitcom needs a fake
game yeah oh I was playing Blaze Rush
yeah
games cars cars would be awesome yeah
install and play something else here we
go here we go here project someone said
watch Lost properly this time they're
defending lost download downloading 20
gigs we got two megabytes down so far
that's not going to work all right let's
pause that that's going to take too long
uh all all right lost this problem
Lucky's T someone said a drift would be
sweet dude we already played a drift we
played a drift it is cool but 20 minutes
ago man wasn't
there
Comfort we are now getting uh about six
or seven layers deep of
Danny on the uh on the green
screen oh whoa if you keep yeah please
keep doing that cuz that will look very
cool as soon as the background kicks in
and all your heads start doing that
together yeah now it's going what's
reaction is started this is weird I
accidentally clicked on something called
jaunt I don't know what it is but it's
got Michelle Obama on the front of it
really that's weird oh it's more
experiences I'm guessing it's going to
be like health and fitness related oh
here we go this is like more like it
this is like higher res I
think NHL Allstar
Weekend or is it going to be as bad it's
going to be as bad isn't it uh that logo
looks pretty pretty
highr no nope
no yeah itry Michelle Obama yeah why is
she there that's weird where the hell
are
you Oculus dream deck what was it
fairlands farlands I can't farlands
farlands what's that farlands the guy
want to say good like Farland the guy is
the guy who made uh Family Guy McFarland
oh where's big far lands bottom right
bottom right oh for us at least uh yeah
guess for be bottom left for you I think
no it's a different screen I'm on all
right let me let me pick
uh coming up Blaze rush I like it let's
get blazed and have a
rush oo please is dope it's basically
something oh it's basically I'm guessing
this say Pokemon Snap that would be
pretty tight
actually cool po on snap and VR actually
would make perfect sense oh totally and
I really want that to be a real thing
yeah
cck I appear to be stuck in the
Assassin's Creed loading screen tight
the end are just walking into an
infinite white Abyss yeah basically can
you see it nope we see oh so that are
you seeing now Danny yeah it's okay you
got to cancel out oh it's busted is it
uh unfortunately if some of these games
if we can't uh if you're seeing it we
can't you can't play them obviously no
wor I'm going to get any that makes
sense it's app failed to close that's
always good okay let's go with if that's
not going to work that's fine we'll just
do something else
windlands what's windlands about let's
check out the details wind a first
person grappling hook exploration game
I'm in I'm in oh I think I saw footage
of this and it looked really cool it's
basically like you're Spider-Man all
right let's check it out are you seeing
you're going to have to quit out of
Blaze Rush Oh
oh it stopped working all right I don't
know and it like picked up on our mics
at all but I really like that Mary's
disembodied voice just like came
emanating from nowhere it's it's profesh
what the hell was that I heard a bang is
that a game or real life uh I think it
was in your headset we did not hear a
bang out here no
worries um okay I'm going to reorientate
myself
there hey Button okay here we are
windlands can you guys see this yes I'm
going to start this game windlands let's
do it start slot three
o let's throw them off ooh uh yeah I'm
pretty sure this is the game I'm
thinking of ooh all right you jump oh
whoa you can jump real high and you can
shoot ropes and swing on them Tarzan
style whoa as
your Center there
whoa
whoa this is weird the whole turning
it's turning at like 45
oh yeah it's looking real choppy on our
on our screen it's not a frame rate
thing it's just like hey what's up buddy
giant geometric robot whoa oh I just
reset myself
ah interesting how it seems like most of
these games have a button that does that
oo oo oh here we go look at
this this seems like it might actually
be really
fun I don't know what button it is but I
do know that you can like I said shoot
shoot ropes you're ready pointed get up
get up get up I'm sure we will unlock it
into and then you don't die no you're
fine you're good uh still still falling
there it goes
yeah all right let's do that again let's
do that again with a bit more be a bit
more delicate maybe once more with Fe
whoa nailed it here we go here we go one
at a time you keep resetting and like
having played recently I keep wanting to
like reset my own head while watching
this it's like really weird so I went
and played a whole bunch of VI games
like a month or two ago and I played
seriously 3 hours worth like basically
straight and by the end like each time I
took off the headset it was harder and
harder to adjust to reality again it was
it's kind of
disorienting w it's it is a little whoa
oh you can wall jump ah interesting this
is kind of cool this is tight yeah I'm
do
this nice jump see the thing is I wish I
could just do that but I got to
go oh wow that's yeah that's super
disorienting especially from like a
presentation standpoint oh hello Mr
grapple
hook what press Folks up they're working
yeah they working I think that tree
above you is was what you want to
do whoa hey yeah now we're making M this
this seems really cool to me W this is
do all right yeah no fall
damage there a distance on this
C I mean this the whole thing seems to
be pretty low gravity so I think you can
kind of just go
nuts uhoh oh man I got like a tree tree
oh wow I got like a like a woozy stomach
for the first time on VR there that was
like real this looks I mean in in a in a
good way kind of in like in an anxious
kind of way right like that feeling when
your stomach kind of jumps into your
show a little bit no no it was like
literally like my orientation was not
like you know when you're on a roller
coaster and it was like a gForce oh yeah
felt like that I like that feeling
though that's where I like your stomach
your stomach raises kind of yeah that
was it was like kind of unnerving
actually damn this looks like one of the
best ones yeah yeah I think um you can
sort of build your momentum and just go
faster and faster and swing through
larger
areas oh no oh that's bad oh that's
bad very dead yeah we should we should
uh give me another little bit on this
then we'll rotate out maybe oh look at
that still got it you're good you're
good yeah getting the hang of this
getting getting in the swing of things
oh here we go pun number three or four I
know I ain't
counting stop pting I'm sorry what are
these these checkpoints yeah it's a
horrible compulsion there we go get up
yeah nice wow that's incredible I like
the big glowing lights they make for
very obvious uh enticing goals this is
like do remember have you any either of
you guys played grow home yeah yeah yeah
imagine playing this imagine like cuz
it's kind of a similar I guess it's like
The Swinging stuff is or the rocket
stuff is like with a traversal yeah yeah
you good I want to see another mechanic
are there any other ones as far as I
know it's jumping and Swinging there
might be more I really like the swing I
don't think combat oh man my stomach
again that was crazy that's tight oh
that's so
strange like I don't get motion sickness
or anything with this stuff I don't miss
anything that was oh the Triforce all
right I got it I was definitely getting
a bit of a Zelda vibe from this game or
it's like witness meets Zelda look at
this thing I mean at least not not in
terms of gamep playay but terms of the
world not of it it's oh God this is
crazy oh big gap oh no
I didn't see anything there I think oh
man this is like a really nice world to
be in it's weird I had that feeling like
when I got in the shadows like oh I'm
out of the sunlight like huh I felt like
o a little bit cooler oh interesting
it's weird who waa you're you're you're
like Pro literally feeling the sunlight
on your skin like a death human brain is
weird yeah he F the G or something this
is very cool that VR can successfully
lighter our brains for us though yeah I
wonder if it can keep it up though I
wonder if it's something that like oh
just get used to Dr oh man it's possible
yeah this game this game would be really
tight if you got like a really uh large
fan and have that blasting one that
actually would be really
cool oh uhoh I know a lot of people are
working on different types of
peripherals that offer um like force
feedback and and in different ways and I
think if you once we're a able to
integrate all these different
Technologies we can end up with some
really cool experiences yeah at GDC they
did have a couple of VR demos with fans
actually nice oh really yeah yeah like
like like just games where you're
outside and stuff yeah exactly like this
game would clearly benefit from fans oh
oh man not really sucks good save hit my
face
up dang do we have a fan around here
we'll just go over and wave at Danny
really hard oh come on and then we'll
smack him when he
dies smacking the face when IAP when I
first walked up I was reading the
comments and somebody kept saying like
slap him slap him right now now when
Mike was playing nice wasn't even
directed to anybody like I don't even
know who he wanted to be slapping Mike
oh man but he was pretty into the idea
of M getting slapped there's been a lot
of talk about the implications of
putting a headset on and just getting
messed with like and having you
know having had people mess with me it's
really uncomfortable like oh I'm sure
you it's not enjoyable in any in any
form obviously it's just the nice thing
about the Vive at least and I don't know
if Oculus has a solution to this as well
but the Vive actually has like a
front-facing built-in face cam um so in
most games you can actually like
basically hit a button and see what's in
front of you in real life CU it'll just
click on the camera yeah um so that'll
kind of help prevent people from messing
with you too much nice so like you could
basically fake someone else out you
could and then when they're to make a
move instead you punch him right in the
face and then you teach him a lesson
like a dog that'll that'll be a great
future live stream punch a lot of dog
like the dog they
are Infamous dog puncher Rob
Handler this is really this is this is
like super good I'm like so into this I
can play this for a while I think what I
love about it is it's so simple but it's
such a cool idea that it doesn't need to
be more really yeah it's oh God it's
like really scary as well it's like
super verticality is great no no no no
no no no you got it you got it yeah yeah
you're fine Baker
look at this [__] where you supposed to
be going I don't know uh I would assume
off in the distance yeah see in the
distance there straight ahead the level
sort of seems to Crescendo and there's
like a light up in the very
top oh man when you miss it it's pretty
it's enjoyable to watch the turning
thing is the only thing that's not cool
serious problem solv when you when
you're stuck in a lower level like how
do you get back up Dam it I wonder if
the Vive would exemplify this experience
like I feel like it probably around so
much right and then that's the issue
with as long as you have that cord
hanging I don't know I'm guessing that
this this my hands are so sweaty I feel
like this doesn't necessarily need
motion controls though like I think a
game pad is actually probably sufficient
for this like the way this game controls
yeah I wonder God yeah I wonder I don't
mean um yeah yeah oh I KN I knew what
you meant but standing able turn around
but you're right no like a like a I mean
maybe that would be cool to like
physically like swing your
arms oh dude I didn't even think about a
Spider-Man game I mean that's kind of
what this is it is but like both arms
yeah well do the move do the move where
you you shoot something and then you
like pull your legs
up like that it's good I like the on the
live stream all we get is your foot
merging
yeah this is really strange like this
you
go there you go full full view very nice
thank you Mary
oh we cut back right as you were falling
whoa oh my God like I'm my stomach's
like dude stop it no this looks super
fun this this is one I would absolutely
play Let's uh let's swap it out in a
little second just yeah to keep
going it's going to be embarrassing
trying to learn after you fully mastered
this like if robber I sits down and
sucks at
it I mean Rob is naturally good at all
games so that will never happen but
are you to no so there is a
distance Danny can you can you uh sort
of dual wield do you do you have access
to multiple ropes or you just oh you're
right I do I do yeah oh that's awesome
that's so cool do it that'll make like
keeping your momentum up so much easier
two once where am I supposed to go then
over here probably uh I yeah I think you
want to go that direction at
I'm pointing as if Danny can see I'm
pointing oh yeah yeah yeah oh no no all
right let's try that again I went I went
South real fast make a cool move yeah
you got this yeah almost no okay it's I
I I I I know what you want me to do it's
just like so hard to do
it I think you're too low I feel like
there's more Act
above you oh there you go that's it this
is it it's kind like every platform
orever where like you you kind of know
that the high road is going to be where
like the best stuff is cuz it's the
hardest road to access I have The High
Ground yes ex here we go I'm going the
chosen one I feel like this area might
be a little bit too hard for I'm going
to go back a little bit see if I can
like do some of that stuff over
here that's tight we got that guy which
I still don't know what that does it
looks like it would be a Teleport or
something I guess just a checkpoint
maybe y oh you're
good this is so messed
up hey Mary if we could get a fan in
here to just strategically blow on
that'd be great
anybody whoa or some leaves we could
some leaves yeah we could rustle or like
throw them at Danny maybe sprinkle them
like majestically handfuls at a time and
do some of that stuff like just swinging
around oh that's cool uh
nope nope you you're still good you're
not falling it you got it you got it no
you don't okay oh my God my stomach is
not okay let me let me go
respawn return to HUB
maybe uh yeah it'll probably take it
back to the very beginning I would guess
I think that's here okay yeah all right
let's I'll see if I'll oh interesting so
I'm guessing the game as a whole is like
Hub and spoke structured so this is
probably like your central area that
leads to a bunch of different swaller
areas that can be like beaten or solved
try find a go to in and then what time
is it are we running over I don't know I
I got my phone hang on hang on it is
2:56 all right so yeah if you wanted to
wrap up by three then we we're running
out of time maybe I'll check over
here see what this thing is this might
be like we're stopping at Three N I
don't I don't think there's like a hard
stop and that was this plan but here we
go let see what's in
here I'm I'm sure the stream wants this
to keep do right guys all right I don't
even know which camera I'm actually
supposed to be looking at I didn't
figure that out oh yeah here we go this
is it this is it this is it
ooh oh yeah this is it you got yeah oh
doing the doing both doing the left and
right hands that's going to make a world
of
difference yeah oh look at this
beautiful Danny that's it best run
Majestic oh we jinxed it I'm
sorry oh even this looks kind of cool
just like Danny's set against the green
screen of what he's playing just looks
kind of cool cuz it now looks like
Danny's torso is flying through this
world I'm
flying I Believe I Can
Fly oh my stomach no don't like that
bit let's Center it
again okay yeah that part is really
disorienting when the camera just snaps
into position real quick I mean I guess
at least you're doing it manually but
still all right let's get someone else
to go on this thing here we
go rob you want to crack at it want me
to jump in there what do you want to do
I'll get you back to that spot
uh want to R Shambo sure do it you want
to go on go on three or go on how we
doing it so R Shambo okay all right
right r i best out of how many uh let's
just do one fair enough R Shambo r Jambo
damn it I shouldn't have done it so does
that mean I'm playing we didn't even
establish okay all right I guess it get
to be my choice it's like
loser the loser gets to
go oh I just realiz where I am I think I
just ran I think I need to run back to
where I just came from I can't I'm
really looking forward to getting out of
this because I feel like like my
stomach's a knots at the
moment I don't like that at
all
okay if you don't want to stop you don't
have oh yeah how you feeling
Danny genuinely stomach like it's like
it's like in
bed you look uncomfortable that was that
was good the look of people like taking
off an Oculus is equivalent to like like
getting up in the morning it's like the
squint the hair they're like oh like oh
it's the same effect as if you were like
born but as an adult like if you just
came out of the womb right and and knew
everything you knew yeah like dude
there's a VR pH yeah right crowning
Oculus birth crowning the game like this
oh
God this is that Ace ventour P scene all
right can kind of hot in these
rhinos okay that was so good yeah I'll
try that after the stream or something
hopefully my levels on the mic sound
good and everything oh I dude I could
tell like you can tell that's what you
getting cuz if you you
know as you're like doing the motion and
you and you screw your body is used to
what you're trying to intend and then
when it's not like [__] falling it's
like a dream how you
doing yeah that's no it's no that's cool
it's just the right stick so like
obviously my brain wants me to use the
right stick instead of my head cuz cuz
I'm so used to like if I'm holding a
game pad that's how this works um so I
need to like not hit the right stick I
think I'm going to just like fingers off
and it
swing see have it your pointing straight
yeah that way and then is it triggers or
triggers you can do them now but it's
only when the reticle glows that you can
you can connect uh did the face button
do anything no nothing a jumps a jumps
okay okay cool ah all right got this oh
okay I noticed the reticle lights up
when it's at right distance okay I'm
just going to drop here and yep okay no
okay did my mic just fall off D hang on
I'm going to die while I reattach my
mic which I can't see hang on Beautiful
Death
soundry no
worries yeah stick it on your yeah on
the yeah sck right there stick all right
we were talking about how cool
Spider-Man take two here we go like
doing this
move
no oh you got it nice and it's a about
letting go as well at the right time
yeah definitely you don't hit into the
you got that's what you were doing a cou
got to maintain your momentum yeah it
takes a good while to getting used to
all right hang on here we
go oh no oh no too far too far dead okay
well I got to learn my limit you're not
going to die if you
sand everyone soof everyone knows
everyone knows that you're [__]
fine sand is even softer in water sand
doesn't hurt play a sand pit how many
people do you know who died from falling
in sand no one has it's a it's a it's
like doing on eating marijuana or
something everyone knows that it's
[__] that works and this way this
way nope okay hang on I got to turn my
camera of crap ah pretty World though as
I fall to the ground yeah it looks good
right
yeah uh I appreciate that they they
didn't go for a photo realistic art
style they went for something more
stylized cuz that's way more achievable
in VR so it it doesn't feel like I'm
actually living this but it's a cool
world to be immersed in so it's I I like
the aesthetic choices that they made oky
do that's oh that's not advisible a hit
a uh you can kind of like can you reel
yourself in kind of yeah like if you're
all right hang on I got to get over here
awesome with some gore in it
like in a tree limb at like you know 80
M hour and just
see guts everywhere I freak you out you
know like a like this but mixed with
like the long dark or Day Z where it's
like super survival oh stop oh stop
Jesus Christ yeah like ARMA mixed with
this you can do it no no NOP okay that
was wasn't close enough M
reset actually looks like you landed on
a Ledge ah did I oh okay hang on nope
you kind of when you hit the ground your
momentum like keeps carrying your
character forward you don't like land
and stop you skid forward a bit so watch
out for that
uh all
right no the other one the other one
yeah yeah I should okay yeah you you'll
get used to the distance it's not like
go for that one there yeah boom left and
then right on the other one oo there we
go which I've already been over here I
got to make it further this time NOP
jump onto the thing CHR get up on the
nope that was the opposite of what I
wanted but I'll okay it's fine oh that
was that almost worked out really well
fine it's not fine man I'm going to get
this I
swear so good I can hear I can hear the
uh the robot near me oh yeah he's coming
for you soon oh yeah yeah all
right oh come on how yeah you just want
to get that like man the like two or
three in a row thing yeah I think I'm
being a little over over
ambitious that was good that was not as
good oh it's there's no tree there yeah
have no momentum now can I swing myself
I can okay here we go this is going to
work I bet there's like an easier area
where we
yeah like learn how to do it kind of
getting the motion sickness you're
talking about right here where I'm like
swinging back and forth my stomach is
still upset it's like not Happ really oh
wait I was on a there's a lower platform
I didn't need to respawn but it's not
like I mean I've I've had that happen uh
where it but it was an immediate like
nauseous effect right but this is more
like like like that I guess that s you
were saying of like falling or might be
a bit nauseous as well yeah this is it
doesn't immediately make me feel
nauseous for you have a big fat meal
right before yeah have you ever been
bungee jumping or skydiving no have you
uh bungee
jumping what was that like it
was like oh you had to let go oh it was
just this feeling of like your your
stomach and your inner just like going
out your feet and it's you guys think I
can make it to that one if I jump
no you need the momentum I'm pretty sure
that whole early section you just got to
hit Y and like just get him one two
three yeah no I think you're right
I feel like I should be better at this
something can I can I get back up how do
I get back up like a Tim bird movie
Something do what are two more goes yeah
yeah yeah rob you want to give the shot
after I fail
again uh-huh right he can't see me
nodding I forgot
mhm she keeps showing YMCA wait what
what is this movie all right I'm going
to go for this cuz I I can't get
anywhere
else is this the intro to dang okay all
right I couldn't make it so I got that
one I got no that should have worked
that
why MCA we're
watching no that's not I don't
know how's your swinging
going
okay describe your swinging uh it's
mainly I am swinging into objects which
is not hit why hit why you've already
you've already messed it you got it I
think yeah you may well be right hey why
I'm going to hang on I'm going just
going not going to do it no it's way too
far
away I'm holding why holding y he's not
problem oh if you hold Y no you're back
here I'm back here all right let's let's
let's wrap this bad boy up fair enough
that's that was good good
swinging mediocre swinging but I
appreciate your positivity you into the
like the the like middle of the that
game but there you go Rob's like oh
you're going to hop in all right yeah go
it yeah give a try I mean you got go on
go three deaths okay three three deaths
I mean
I 40 minutes and by three I mean
30 get it so we ey this room dude I was
I was bad at that but importantly I
absolutely want to keep playing that
game yeah yeah it was good right uh like
I I am ex I was enjoying my time
and like I'm sad that I had to stop and
let Rob play so that's a good sign that
there's an actual game out there
that's I mean this ain't no uh Into the
Dead that game that game's a [__]
running into the
dead it's no watching Bono sing
intimately to us in a stadium what is
wait why can't be the
same uh is there a Sprint is going to
take uh there's a jump that's it so uh a
is Jump left and right trigger are the
the grapples and why why are these like
45 degree turns yeah so that's the way
it's like basically centering so don't
ever touch that unless you're like
you're once you've like turned around a
couple times or something or you need to
like make a right angle turn or
something yeah it's done you can
definitely see how the difficulty in
this game could ramp up because there
will be sections that will force you to
sort of go around a curve and you'll
have no choice but to adjust the camera
as you go which is disorienting yeah
maybe or maybe they shy away from that
you never yeah possible probably going
to chain a bunch of them yeah there you
go yeah you got it oh Rob's a pro Rob's
a pro look at
this Spidey sens are tingling yeah so
now is going to use your right trigger
to kind of Center
yourself look at this guy Batman oh oh
no yep yeah it's all good until you run
out of trees and then it's like wait
something's gone terribly wrong this is
this is easily the best game I've played
yeah yeah in are yeah already who I mean
it's seriously a lot of
fun I am curious if there are like
broader goals cuz the game is takes the
very witness approach nice
save or not okay it's just s it's
fine I'll be okay I just dust myself
those are the only buttons I get yeah
yeah as far as we can tell yeah can I
like warp to different area the other
area you guys were in was way cooler oh
to the right or go behind you the way
you came yeah like the tall glowing blue
like pains or sort of like teleporters
to different
areas yeah that that
guy which yeah I think this might take
you to the area where I was but I'm not
certain yeah it's the one we were just
in a second
ago have
fun thanks do
it let's do it oh
yeah
damn
it it's okay that music's trademarked
anyways you almost got to like do the
yeah I like early
right wow yeah what's what's really
fascinating that is you may not realize
until you play it is your aiming is
dependent on your head movement like you
need to be looking at the right thing in
order to be able to attach yourself to a
tree beautiful nicely done pro which is
really cool because then it links like
the fact that you're in VR directly to
the gameplay mechanics uh which a lot of
VR games do not do so like your use of
the VR headset directly impacts your
success in the game yeah looking is
generally what they're using framing
though right in shooting games and stuff
like with the any first person ones yeah
for first person shooters oh I can jump
a lot of games definitely use that but
it's I think it's just interesting to
see a different application um that like
it uses a your your view as a traversal
system as opposed to an Aiming system or
part of a traversal
system this is the problem I kept having
I would just get stuck in it be cool to
like lose slack right there you go you
got it you got it yeah you're okay
you're on the track
nice almost It's Tricky all right one
last time good yeah you got it you're
one last time oh did you oh you're back
here oh that's still oh I got hit these
checkpoints yeah I'm not really doing
that
we're almost 35 there you go wait for
it oh you're right you really do get
that yeah that that stop which is great
that's like really
great cuz that's when you're like
slipping off and you're like no you want
to go back right like yeah that's cool
all
right yeah screw the
runway [__] doing
good nope okay
what is this music from so it's so
similar I another thing I really like oh
nicely done uh another thing I really
like about this game is that you can see
why you failed and ever feels like you
got cheated into a death you're always
like ah I screwed up so it feels valid
it feels like you can overcome it
because you know what you have to do
nice work there you go you got it you
got it good one more yeah okay good just
reel it in yes okay you're good you're
the there oh the look is so weird yeah
right about that go to to the checkpoint
yeah yeah yeah hit the hit the
checkpoint good call D cuz this is this
is this is where I kept dying this is
the part that I couldn't beat so you
will need that checkpoint if you're
anything like me I think he's got
us almost that last one that last
one look at this
guy
what yeah that's where it meant to be
[Music]
beautiful now we can hit Y to go back if
you if you need to oh come on so good so
good okay all right maybe one big swing
with that
guy there you go yes yes nice checkpoint
nice work you gone farther than both of
us cuz I watched you guys for for
probably a while I learned it by
watching
you
nope yeah when you screw up you kind of
know right away like well it's it's just
like not worth your time or something
like but is really cool that it you can
just hit Y and it warps you back to your
most recent thing huh definitely
alleviates potential
frustration my brain is already in like
reviewer
mode checkpointing system check
what are you doing Rob I'm trying to get
some speed Danny oh the double is
sick oh oh yeah hit the ground a little
slows you down but you're you're I had
it you had it I had it oh oh no s all
right one more go one more
go oh yeah look at this whoa okay you're
good you're going to make it you're
going to make it nice keep going that
was beautiful that was the best swing so
far yeah Spiderman
H spider no up we
go nice oh look at this oh yeah there
you go yeah you're going to make it you
got the momentum you're just going to
hit sure that worked that looks like a
goal like not even dude this is the best
game ever oh keep going it looks like
you're uh like beat the level can you
like jump down that is that a big hole
Yeah
Jump The
Gap
cool you go through a portal door this
is [__] dumb you walk into that
right uh nope you're actually just
trapped forever you can wall you can
jump double wallum oh yeah oh yeah I
forgot the wall well is this something
then don't think so I think it's just
saying go
up why did it let you jump down here
it's just a pit maybe it's a way to uh
it looks so inviting oh you know what I
actually you know what I think we just
did I think we just did the first level
backwards we might have oh cuz didn't
you start there yeah I think so yeah
well I'm which makes sense because uh in
the hub world we like turned around and
went back all right well I'm I'm going
to play die and we'll CAU maybe trickier
than uh we should have been cuz we were
doing the whole thing in the reverse
order it was intended to be totally yeah
Rob what did you say uh how about I I
just get another run until I die yeah
sure go on sure
yeah this is way easier God
sorry
whoa wind sound effects as you
[Music]
swinging oh [__] no I'm not like this oh
you're not
dead see I'm getting like strong
Renaissance Fair vibes from from this
new yeah not not bad way
oo no no no no no
no you got this Rob you're good you're
all
good dude it's just sand don't worry
about it it's just sand you big
[__] you got
it spelunk your way up there oh that's
why I keep forgetting about like yeah
really low gravity on the jumps they can
no but like wall jumping and just I
don't know parkour General okay uh a
yeah it highlighted on that tree on the
right on your on your left oh I know you
know he's just check you got to get a
plan in dude all right plan of
action
nice cross that's nasty Crossing them
over like that
[Laughter]
[__] God bet like bug testing this stuff
must be a nightmare oh my God for like
your stomach and everything my stomach
is still at me I actually I haven't
really had any of that yet yeah I there
were a couple little moments for me but
nothing nothing bad I have had an I
didn't have any lunch so maybe yeah I'm
just maybe I'm just hungry I'm running
on free office bagels and
caffeine B on Friday guys it's great rob
you might have it on the way back you
might have the whole way this may be the
longest any of us survived though oh
totally yeah he's a pro I feel like I'm
Dr Octopus or from yeah
Peter Parker I'm
coming come
here all
right yeah you
got jeez good almost there dude you
almost you almost did the length and
breadth of this level here we go here we
go it's going to be good got this yeah
see that guy oh no okay he's yeah nice
whoa that's the [__] coolest thing
ever up
and for you and for you and for you it's
amazing that's so
good here we go you can do it final
stretch I got to go there right yeah
yes yeah don't worry about that
bush all right do it look at the
pressure he's under this is amazing
believe in you rob SP
Rob whoa oh look at you beautifully
nailed it only one left to go if I had
one of those like gous judges scorecards
I would be holding up nine for you yeah
quite pretty easy sticks The Landing
he's going you're going to mess this up
now cuz you said it was so
easy yeah I probably should have said
that you got to jump on that thing I
think for yeah I think you can just jump
this
one although you will slide off nice oh
beautifully done beautifully done Rob
beautiful work of
art d
boom congratulations that is wildlands
get back to the oh wildlands I was about
to say go back to the menu cuz I forgot
the name of the game but there oh my God
Rob your parkouring so good right now
amazing would I keep going or no
we yeah we may be watching Spider-Man
footage behind you you're doing great
you're doing great you're parkouring so
hard all right well then I'll [__]
keep playing thank you so much Scott
byworth and Mike mahen coming on of
course Rob handre with your googly
eyes good VR in there Rob good
love the robot friend for hanging out
with us all day today as well robot
friend awesome oh my God this is look at
this this is awful thanks so much for
everyone watching on
twitch.tv Gamespot gamespot.com and on
YouTube gaming as well uh thank you so
much for watching we'll be back next
week Lobby 2 p.m
Pacific on Tuesday have a great weekend
everyone happy weekend happy Friday Hi
Mom Happy April Fool
no NE the grass Tyson this time gravity
not a game thanks so much mer in the
back we'll see you guys next week bye
see
you there we go nope almost uh I can't
tell we got the we got the Fade Out
thing I'm just going take the mic
off
great